Over the past few months, I’ve noticed a number
of comments all expressing something similar,
with that thing being the idea that tutors, cards
that search a player’s library, are in some way
out of place within the landscape of casual EDH,
or at least within the landscape of lower power
levels. In particular, I’ve encountered this
when I discuss cards that are quite powerful
compared to everything else in deck. I’ve at times
brought up the scenario of a powerful card being
an obvious tutoring target, sometimes in a way I
find uninteresting, and a common response I get
is “well why are you playing a tutor then? That’s
your problem right there.” On an objective level,
this person isn’t wrong. The tutor is part
of the immediate problem here, and I wouldn’t
be having an obvious card to grab if I wasn’t
grabbing anything in the first place. However,
there are some deeper disagreements taking place
here, disagreements about the foundations of EDH
and what it stands for. So in this video,
I want to explore those disagreements,
and to discuss the nature of variance,
variation, and luck, and what role these
things should play within an EDH game. Different
players will have different ideas about how much
of these things should be present in a game of
commander, and these opinions are often phrased
as proclamations about what falls within the
“spirit” of the format. So, what does this mean?
Well, the best way to dig into this is to look
at the way EDH differs from other magic formats.
Decks are 99 or 98 cards, significantly more than
the 60 seen in traditional constructed formats,
and the 40 seen in limited decks. EDH also has a
one-copy limit on cards within decks as compared
to the four card limit for 60 card formats, and
together these restrictions make it so that for
any given card, a deck will often be around
a sixth as likely to draw it in an EDH deck
as compared to a 60 card deck. This fact alone
has led many people to make the observation that
EDH is a higher variance format than most others.
For the non-mathy folks, the word variance sounds
like the word variation, and that’s actually
not an incorrect way to think about some of the
implications of these numerical realities. Because
there are more different cards, each with a lower
average chance to get drawn, there will be more
variation in the cards that get played within a
game and between different games. As a result of
this, decks will generally feel new and fresh for
longer, and play patterns within a game are often
less predictable. All of this is great as far as
I’m concerned! Recently I’ve had a strong interest
in decks containing lots of subthemes that can
combine in all sorts of ways. The challenge
of optimizing and tuning a deck like this to
actually play well is a blast, and it’s a blast
that could only exist in a format like EDH. Within
this sort of synergy-machine deck, tutors can be
a helpful tool to help an otherwise disjointed
deck actually play nicely, but excluding tutors
can likewise be a fun challenge that forces an
even greater degree of deck cohesion. Some
people choose to play the EDH format at a
power level that demands a greater degree of
consistency in cards available, but a high
degree of card and play variation is absolutely
an enjoyable thing to cultivate where possible.
All of this sounds good and agreeable, but
something you may have noticed is that this
pedestrian interpretation of the phrase “variance”
has strayed pretty far from the sort of scenario
I mentioned at start of this video. I’m not
thinking about whether you’d use a tutor to
find any old card—no, I’m talking about situations
when a player uses a tutor to find some piece of
degenerate nonsense, a card that will dramatically
impact how powerfully your deck plays. To tackle
that question, we need to talk about variance in
the mathematical sense, and we need to talk about
it in terms of how it applies to power level.
The power level variance of a deck basically
refers to how widely a deck’s power level
differs moment-to-moment and game-to-game.
This is difficult to track exactly, and obviously
in a multiplayer format like commander a deck’s
moment-to-moment power level won’t always
directly translate into wins or losses,
but most people are going to have an intuitive
idea of what I’m talking about. When a deck is
progressing effectively toward goals that
will lead to winning a game, it’s having
a more powerful game. If a deck has access to
a powerful card like Sol Ring or Skull Clamp,
it’s going to be having a better time on average
than if it instead had access to Mind Stone or
Rogue’s Gloves. If you take nothing else away from
this video, understand that a game with a lot of
card variation is different from a game with
a lot of power level variance—you can have one
without the other, and a defense of one of these
things isn’t necessarily a defense of the other.
When it’s already a foregone conclusion that a
powerful card is going to exist in your deck,
the question of whether to run tutors for it
then becomes the question of whether you’d
prefer to have that powerful card frequently or
infrequently. On a probabilistic level, the deck
that runs the tutors will be more powerful than
the deck that does not. Let’s say we’re using a,
I don’t know, 7-point power scale. That’s a fun
number. If drawing into a particular power card
naturally leads to a 6-power game, tutoring
it leads to a 5-power game due to the extra
cost and/or inconvenience of the tutor, and
not having the card leads to a 3-power game,
the expected power of the deck that runs tutors
will be higher than the deck that does not.
If you’re then figuring out what power level
to put the deck in and you’re a certified math
dork running the odds, you could say “well the
expected power level of the tutor version is 4.1,
and the expected power level of the non-tutor
version is a 3.3,” and then this could determine
the decks you choose to play this deck against.
Problem is, both of these decks are gonna have
that power level 6 game 10% of the time, it’s
just that one set of opponents is going to be
a bit better prepared for that situation than
the others. This abstract approach demonstrates
the core of the issue with decks having a
higher degree of power level variance, but
that abstractness makes it a bit less helpful in
understanding real world cards, because different
powerful cards accomplish very different tasks.
So, let’s talk about some real world magic cards.
For starters, let’s talk about the quintessential
card in this sort of discussion—Sol Ring.
I’ve been jokingly calling this card “my Wizards
of the Coast mandated dose of variance” whenever
I draw it for the past several months, and it
truly is a massive injection of variance. It’s
one of the most powerful cards in the game,
indisputably the most powerful mana rock in
the format after the banning of Mana Crypt, and
it’s been printed in every precon out there.
So this should be an example of the great woes
inflicted by power level variance, right? Well,
not exactly, and this is where things get more
nuanced. Sol Ring is indisputably powerful,
but its power is somewhat less felt than a lot
of other cards, and this is for a few reasons.
First of all, it only provides mana—if you don’t
have good things to do with that mana, it’s not
going to be all that powerful. Decks still have
commanders, a bonus card they can cast at any
time, so it’s rarely useless, but it might only be
modestly powerful in some circumstances. Secondly,
it’s a low cost card. 1 mana for a rock that taps
for two colorless mana is insanely powerful, yes,
but that power falls off rapidly, and drawing
it past turn five or so might not even be that
desirable. Thirdly, it’s a card that is
typically far back in the progression of
winning a game. If we think of a deck as having a
pipeline that runs from the start of the game to
the hypothetical point at which it wins, Sol Ring
falls right near the beginning of that pipeline.
Since commander is a multiplayer format, this will
often give opponents a lot of time to collaborate
in slowing down the Sol Ring-ing player, negating
some of the power level bump of the card.
Now, does all of this mean that Sol Ring’s
power is something that never feels bad?
Absolutely not. The most problematic instances
of Sol Ring tend to be where there was already
a bit of power level imbalance between decks,
and especially if some of the weaker players
kept poor hands or had unlucky openings. Sol Ring
can be an equalizing tool for the weakest players,
but it can also be drawn by the person piloting
the most powerful deck, boosting what might have
been a workable game into an outright pub stomp.
Calls to ban Sol Ring, or now to put it on the
Gamechangers list, exist for a reason—the card
is far from the bane of the format’s existence,
but it’s also not a perfectly unproblematic tool,
and that makes it a good place to start. Following
the pipeline model, what falls on the opposite
end of the line? Well, it’s ways to win the game,
typically ones that are near instantaneous such
as combos or combo-adjacent cards. These tend
to lead to the most jarring instances of power
level variance, because the table doesn’t have
much time to react—you go from playing the
game to having it end without enough time
for any sort of table-coordinated response.
I’ll elaborate more on why this sort of thing
constitutes a problem in a bit, but naturally
when there is a problem, a card that wins the
game immediately will be the problem-iest.
Incidentally, this pipeline model also makes
it clear that removal can be a tool for power
level variance mitigation on the scale of a game.
Between Sol Ring and cards that outright win
the game will be a bunch of cards somewhere
in the realm of what might be considered an
“engine”. The engines that only provide card
advantage will typically be closer to Sol Ring
in terms of their position on the pipeline—card
advantage is quite good, yes, but it can take
a little while to fully pay off into a win,
since mana will still be a limitation. The One
Ring will feel quite powerful, but the table
should still have a decent bit of time to work
together and stop a one-ringing player if they
start to get out of hand. The engines that are
further down the pipeline are ones that grant mana
in some form as well—think something like Bolas’s
Citadel or Arcane Bombardment. When one of these
hits the board, the table might be a single turn
cycle away from fully losing control of the game,
or even less in some cases. So this
is the four point model I like to go
with—you’ve got your early game stuff that
is more of a temporary boost than anything,
you’ve got your mid-game engines that can
start to push out of control if given time,
you’ve got your late-game engines that
signal an imminent threat to your opponents,
and you’ve got your truly game-ending cards
at the very end here. Obviously these are
categories defined by specific sorts of cards,
but it’s possible to categorize basically every
proactive magic card into one of these based on
how imminently they threaten opponents in a game
when they might be considered powerful. And that’s
the key here—the utility of these categories is in
analyzing a card that already seems like
a possible power level outlier of sorts.
Power level variance will feel sharper the
further along this pipeline a card is due to the
social nature of the EDH format—as I mentioned
earlier, a Sol Ring is quite possible to play
around with and typically only an out-of-control
power spike in very specific scenarios where there
were other factors lining up at the same time. By
contrast, there are all sorts of scenarios where a
Craterhoof Behemoth or a Mizzix Mastery might feel
like a shocking or unsatisfying turn of events.
And fundamentally, that’s my broader problem with
power level variance as well. The wider a deck’s
play patterns span in their power, the more
difficult it is to put together good matchups,
and the less satisfying games will be. Let’s
think about a mid-power Raccoon deck—we’re
doing a bit of ramping, playing some raccoons,
and then maybe throwing down some cool top-end
spells once we’ve built up our mana. But now
let’s say the deck contains a Godo-Helm combo
in it that can instantly win the game if the Godo
is drawn and the deck has enough mana. Or heck,
maybe even just a few especially strong top end
creatures. What power level of game do you play
this deck in? You could play it alongside other
flavorful mid-power decks, but you might randomly
smash them with an out-of-character power play.
Alternatively you could play with other decks that
have some higher-caliber plays, but then you might
just get destroyed when you only draw into a bunch
of fair-magic raccoon friends. When decks have
such a high degree of power level variance, it’s
hard to find a fair game to play them in, and if
you choose your game based on the fair 80% of the
time gameplan, the other people at the table may
be in for a rude awakening when you draw the 20%.
In addition, even if you find a table
that seems suitable enough for the deck,
this degree of randomness is destructive to a
lot of the things that make commander a great
format to me. One of the most important elements
of the format is its multiplayer feature—you’re
playing alongside three other people, and games
often require strategizing and performing threat
analysis, figuring out the best way to navigate
the landscape in front of you. The issue with
decks that have a high power level variance,
then, is that they make threat assessment almost
impossible. There is no landscape if you’re
playing against a bunch of decks that do a
mixture of power plays and durdling around
vague synergies accomplishing very little.
You could target down the person who currently
has the most threatening thing on board—maybe
this is where some people like to stop with threat
assessment, who knows—but you can’t ask yourself,
what will these decks be doing later? Do I have
any sort of clock I need to worry about from this
player like some sort of combo gameplan they’re
assembling, or will this other player get ahead
with overwhelming value if they aren’t pressured
now? This information is unknowable if the power
of a deck’s gameplan is determined by raw chance,
and the end result is that commander turns into a
luck game—it’s seeing who draws the powerful stuff
and who puts it together at the right time and who
happens to have the exact answer available at the
exact right time. To some players, this is likely
fine, good even. Commander is a very diverse
format with lots of people looking for lots
of different things out of it. You’re allowed to
enjoy the more luck-based version of Magic where
concepts like strategy and threat assessment are
reduced down to a shadow of their usual selves,
but you should at least be able to understand why
if other people don’t want to play a commander
game somewhere along the lines of Wizard-flavored
Yahtzee or Dragon-themed Bingo with you.
Obviously I have strong personal feelings about
what degree of power level variance I find fun
in a game, but rather than spending too much time
berating you with that, I think it’s worth asking
another question: why do so many people end
up with decks that might be considered higher
variance? Some of it is likely intentional,
but a lot of it comes down to the nature of
the EDH format and the culture that has developed
around it. EDH is naturally a format where plays
need to be larger in scale, and this is for
two simple reasons: life totals are doubled,
and there are two extra opponents. Naturally,
then, it’s common to see a lot more cards that
are synergistic—they rely on other cards for some
of their power. This is not, in and of itself,
a bad thing, and a well-thought-out synergy
package can make for a fantastic backbone of a
deck. However, when packages are narrower,
when they don’t tie together as well,
and when decks go overboard on certain types of
payoff, problems can arise. It’s pretty common
to see decks with a lot of cards that are only
good when the deck is in a specific situation,
like having an ideal boardstate, having specific
types of support, being ahead in some way,
and so on. This is common to see because humans
are bad at thinking about chance. Let’s say you
have a little micro-package with six enabler
cards and four payoff cards for a particular
thing. What are the odds that these actually
show up together in the top 15 cards of your
library? The answer is probably lower than you
think—there’s about a 64% chance you’ll have one
of the enablers, a 49% chance you’ll have one of
the payoffs, and a 30% chance you’ll have both.
This means for any time you’ve drawn one
of the six enablers in the top 15 cards of
your library, there’s a 47% chance you have one
of the four payoffs, and if you’ve drawn one of
the four payoffs there’s a 61% chance you’ve
drawn one of the enablers. And that’s not even
considering whether or not you have the mana
to cast these things—take that into account
and you’re probably south of 25% of the time.
Long story short, humans are exceptionally bad
at thinking about the probability of multiple
things lining up just right at the same time.
For a little analogy, this is why sports betting
apps make a killing on parlays, bets on multiple
specific things within a game happening. People
make these bets because the payouts are higher,
but in reality the probability of multiple things
happening at the same time is typically low enough
that these bets end up having massive margins
for the apps, even with the higher payout.
Taking things back to deckbuilding, this fact
of probability means that if you run a bunch
of cards that are mainly only good alongside
other cards, or mainly only good when you’re
already in a decent situation, you’re
going to end up with a high-variance deck,
and not in a way that I’d find fun. You’ll have
some games where cards show up together at just
the right time and you’re able to take over the
game, and other games where things don’t come
together right and you end up puttering around
on the sidelines while more consistent decks are
able to actually play the game. And this is to say
nothing of the relationship these decks have with
removal—a deck that hinges on being ahead,
on having a specific situation be the case,
even simply on having its commander stick around
long term—well, that’s a deck that’s going to
have a rough time against an opponent who has the
interaction to keep it in check. If an opponent
has seen your deck performing well and performing
well means going absolutely ham on the board,
they’re going to try and slow you down. If your
deck also putters around doing nothing when it
has a key piece removed, well, you’ve just set
yourself up for a one-two punch of not having fun.
You might also call this sort of a deck a “feast
or famine” deck—when it’s able to do its thing it
dominates whatever game it’s in, but when certain
key pieces are kept off the board by either bad
luck or opposing interaction, the rest of the
deck’s cards aren’t able to do much of anything.
Another thing that contributes to a high degree
of power level variance within EDH is that
people feel more willing to put especially
powerful cards in decks when those cards
work with their commander in some play. You’ll
certainly occasionally see people who’ll toss
powerful infinite combos like Heliod/Ballista
or Dualcaster/Twinflame in any old deck they
can cram it into, but it’s much more common
to see people throw in cards that combo with
their commander. In my video on the subject
of turning commanders into a combo piece,
I bring up that large percentages of both Zaxara
players and Tivit players play one-card infinite
combos with their respective commanders. This
isn’t great when it occurs in a deck that is
otherwise winning in decidedly mid-power,
fair magic sorts of ways such sacrificing
clues with a Disciple of the Vault in play
or swinging in with a handful of normal-sized
hydras. This is true for the reason I mentioned
earlier—turning games into a strategy-devoid,
swingy luckfest—but also because it can impact
the threat assessment of your opponents, causing
you to attract extra hate even when you’re playing
with the decidedly fair-magic half of your deck.
So, why do people choose to make this sort
of deckbuilding choice? On some level,
the existence of these power cards probably feels
like a gift—the sort of play that would feel out
of place in a deck is rendered acceptable to
people due to it tying in with their commander
or a major theme in their deck. It is, as I would
jokingly say about Sol Ring, a prescribed dose of
variance that has been handed down by the abstract
godlike figure that is Wizards of the Coast.
The same goes for cards more in the realm of
engines. I gave a couple more minor examples of
this in a recent video—Waste Not for a discard
deck and Monument to Endurance for a cycling
deck—but there are numerous examples of commanders
or archetypes with one specific mid-game card that
goes absolutely crazy. Skullclamp with tokens,
Thrumming Stone in a Shadowborn Apostle deck,
Colossus Hammer in an Ardenn deck, and so on.
However, I want to focus in on one in particular
as an illustrative example—Krark’s Thumb in
a Yusri deck. Yusri is a commander that flips
up to five coins when he attacks—most people
choose five—and then his controller then draws
a card for each heads and takes 2 damage for each
tails. If five heads are hit, you get a temporary
omniscience—spells are free to cast until end of
turn. On its face, this is a spicy commander—if
we do the math, this is basically a creature
with two-and-a-half double damage Phyrexian
Arenas stapled to it, and which also gives
a roughly 3% chance of an Omniscience turn.
What happens to these numbers when a Krark’s Thumb
is played, a card run in 91% of Yusri decks? Well,
the impact of improving the coin flipping
odds is pretty dramatic with five coins
flipped per turn—average cards drawn per turn
goes up from 2.5 to 3.75, average damage taken
goes from 5 down to 2.5, and this means that
average damage per card gets cut down by two
thirds. Even more dramatically, the odds of an
Omniscience turn are almost eightfold improved,
now sitting at just below a 24% chance.
And that’s an Omniscience on a turn where
5 extra cards were drawn—it’s not hard
to imagine situations where the game
is won either right then and there or rapidly
thereafter, even reasonably early in the game.
I don’t think you need me to tell you that this
card constitutes an almost absurd degree of power
enhancement for a deck Yusri when played.
So, is this reasonable as a variance spike?
Is it good for a deck’s commander to normally
be a potent-yet-painful draw engine and in a
much smaller number of cases become a much more
powerful draw engine without the risk and with
a one quarter chance each turn of offering a
quite-possibly-game-winning benefit? I don’t
necessarily want to answer that question for
you. In part because it’s more complicated than
something like an infinite combo, and also in part
because Yusri is a commander that already selects
for players who are looking for somewhat of a
luck-based experience, so I’m probably not going
to be convincing that person that this is any sort
of negative thing even if I wanted to stake out a
position. I’m merely bringing attention to this as
an example of EDH culture in a nutshell—the fact
that a full 91% of players are running Krark’s
Thumb demonstrates the universality of this sort
of good-cards-are-a-gift mentality, even in a
casual format. It’s also at this point that I
want to turn things back around to the question
of tutors. Here’s a question—is it better if
a Yusri player runs tutors to find the Krark’s
Thumb, or is it better if they allow lady luck
to run her course and bring them the thumb when
she deems it appropriate? I think a lot of people
are going to naturally default to the no-tutors
option there, but why is that? If you’re going
to be playing powerful stuff, isn’t it better to
have it more consistently, and also to give your
opponent the chance to strategize, to consider
their options, to weigh the risks of different
plays? Is it better that they play against
a janky coin-flipping deck that occasionally
throws on the gas randomly and then 24% of
the time has that gas turn into rocket fuel?
You can feel however you like about those
questions, and I think it’s entirely reasonable
to have some mixed feelings about this sort of
thing. However, this example does start to clarify
the impact of tutors on power level variance,
particularly in a deck containing more powerful
cards. If you’re playing a deck with a handful
of power cards amidst a number of worse cards,
running tutors to improve your chances of drawing
said power cards will lead to less swinginess,
since you have access to the power card with
some degree of consistency rather than only in
a handful of games. However, this usage of tutors
is naturally sacrificing deck variation—you’re
going to be making more similar plays every game.
This can still be cool if you’re running a sort of
secret commander deck where you’re able to
build off of the consistently-tutored card
in a variety of different ways as you might do
with a commander, but this is likely a minority
of cases. This brings me to the second usage of
tutors here—tutors can help you in the process of
identifying cards that might be out of place
in terms of their power level variance.
To build off of a real world example, I recently
heard a content creator discuss an experience they
had that caused them to cut the tutors from one
of their decks. They had tutors in their Vela,
the Night Clad deck, and they found that all too
often they would tutor for Rite of Replication,
a card that can copy Vela 5 times to deal 30
damage to each opponent. This is a one-card
combo that will instantly win the game in
many situations, if a very mana-intensive one.
The Vela player found this a bit anticlimactic
and their response to this was to cut the tutors,
but when I heard this my first thought was
“wow, think about the gift your tutors just
gave you!” Like, these tutors have identified
a card that is exceptional enough to be the
correct tutoring choice most of the time and
have also given you the chance to decide that
that exceptionality feels a bit off, and in the
process have given you the chance to indulge a
bit and play that card a few final times. Put
in more general terms, tutors let you see what
cards you’re gravitating toward, and they also
give you extra opportunities to decide how you
feel about a card. If you’re tutoring for a card
a lot, you can ask yourself “have I been enjoying
having this card more often?” If the answer is
yes, great! All is well. If the answer is no,
well that gives you the opportunity to make some
choices. It might be that the card is out of place
in your deck, but it also might be that the card
represents a gameplan that was fun for a bit,
but that you’ve already gotten your full amount of
enjoyment out of for the moment. In either case,
you now have the opportunity to try
something new instead of that card.
In my most tutor-intensive deck, my Sharuum Slide
deck, I’ve always performing exactly this sort of
analysis. There’s obviously the part of the
deck pertaining to the flicker enchantments,
and I never get tired of those since they’re what
the deck is built around, but my artifact-fetching
wizards give me the opportunity to see what
I tutor for, and which of those things feel
satisfying when played a lot. The only cards I
find myself tutoring for first every time are
Sol Ring and Fluctuator, and both of these I’m
fine with since Sol Ring is just mana advantage
and Fluctuator is a core card I can play around.
On the other end of things, Portal to Phyrexia is
a powerful card I was worried I’d be tutoring for
too often with my treasure mage, but that really
hasn’t been the case. There are just so many
useful top end artifacts in the deck between
wincons, removal of various types, lifegain, and
other utility cards. In fact, Portal hasn’t even
been my most common target for Treasure Mage—that
honor goes to Angel of the Ruins, though even then
I’d say that’s only my pick about 30-40% of the
time. Part of the joy of a toolbox deck is the
action of figuring out the right tool for the job,
and balancing tutor targets so that they all get
the chance to be the correct pick across different
situations is a great way to optimize the fun
of a deck like this. This act also naturally
smooths out the power level of different cards,
making for a more consistent experience
with my draws in addition to my tutoring.
Ultimately, whether or not you add tutors to a
deck is a personal decision and I’m not really
trying to sway you one way or the other on that.
I presented these four quadrants in my last video
to illustrate four different philosophies
on whether to tutor for a powerful card,
and returning to them now can illustrate
how deckbuilding decisions play out. In
a deck with a handful of more powerful cards,
including tutors will likely reduce the power
level variance of the deck and lead to a smoother
game-to-game experience, but it will also likely
have the side effect of reducing card and play
variation, making the deck more samey. This puts
a deck in the first quadrant. Not including
tutors will do the opposite—decks will have a
greater variety of different plays game-to-game,
but they may have sudden power level spikes
here or there when a powerful card is drawn.
This puts a deck in the third quadrant here.
The fourth quadrant is one where most cards that
might spike a deck’s power level are weeded out,
but tutors are still included. This is a
generally low-power-level-variance style of deck,
and the play variation of this sort of deck
really depends on its pilot. Some people might
value getting different cards each time and
combining them in different and creative ways,
whereas others might look for a more consistent
play pattern with less variety. A final fifth
category might be a deck that contains neither
any major power outliers nor any tutors,
and this sort of deck would most likely be both
high variation and low power level variance.
Ultimately, the biggest thing I want to get across
here is that these two things are two separate
knobs. The tutor conflict within the casual EDH
community isn’t a battle between the people who
want different things every game and people who
want the same experience every game, nor is it a
fight between skill-havers and luck-enjoyers, nor
a duel between good players and bad players, nor a
skirmish between pubstompers and fun-havers. There
will be elements from some of those dialectical
clashes present, but so are a lot of other
things, including some I mentioned in my last
video. However you choose to build your decks,
the best I can hope for is that the frameworks
I’ve laid out over the past half hour might be
helpful in the goal of building something fun.